sur les questions qui ont été posées et
qui ont dimension politique très forte
d'abord la question de la droite
question éruptive j'essaierai de vous
faire débattre sur le sujet nous sommes
la droite républicaine mais nous ne
sommes pas que la droite républicaine
nous devons tout à la fois affirmer une
identité très forte et en même temps ne
pas nous couper d'une partie de
l'électorat dont nous avons besoin pour
gagner les élections ne nous
caricaturons pas défendons fortement
notre identité mais nous nous réduisons
pas
c'est un débat que je vous proposerai
est ce que par exemple les républicains
c'est toujours l'alliance de la droite
républicaine du centre des gaullistes
des libéraux ou pas moi je le souhaite
je ne le vois pas comme un compromis
bancal
je le vois comme une addition dans un
pays 66 millions d'habitants que nous
pouvons pas réduire un seul courant de
pensée la diversité dieu sait que je me
suis battu pour la diversité
dieu sait que j'ai donné la
responsabilité à des ministres je pense
à rachida dati
je pense à une petite française n'est
fait ayant vécu à dakar jusqu'à 8 ans je
ne regrette pas ses joueurs nous ne
sommes pas l'eau partie d'une seule
culture
nous sommes le parti de la france et la
france est diverse et multiple et je ne
veux pas d'un parti politique ou tous
ressemblerait à tous c'est pour ça que
j'étais renée pendant les élections
régionales à prendre mes responsabilités
en disant clairement que pour moi la
france n'est pas une race la france
renaît à l'esprit c'est une histoire
c'est un amour c'est une culture c'est
une langue c'est une passion
ce n'est pas quelque chose que l'on peut
réduire plus facile à dire qu'à faire
parce que chacun aime à me demander la
diversité et a le plus grand mal à
respecter la diversité chez les autres
les investitures aux législatives
j'en ai parlé avec mon ami alain juppé
que je salue d'ailleurs et que je
remercie de participer à nos travaux
cher alain dans notre famille est dans
ta famille
je veux répondre à la question qui m'a
donc été posée par mme je crois
madeleine pour moi le choix est clair
un mouvement politique en ordre c'est un
mouvement politique direction certes
hier pas d'homme providentiel mais une
organisation capin leader un patron un
organisateur
c'est pas une organisation c'est la
pagaille donc peut-être qu'il faut
trouver l'équilibré entre les deux je
connais pas une mairie qui marche sans
mère un département qui marche au
président un parti qui marche soit
président une société qui marque son
quelqu'un moment un cas un projet ce
sera bien le cas des présidentielles
pour moi il faut déconnecter les
investitures l'islate yves de la
primaire il ne faut pas mettre les
parlementaires et les candidats otage
des primaires il faut donc donner les
investitures au printemps pour
débarrasser la primaire de la logique
des clans des équipes
on choisir un candidat non pas parce
qu'il est mieux pour gagner chez
christian mais parce qu'il est le plus
copains de celui dont on espère ou de
celle qui sortira premier des primaires
est ce qu'on pourra trouver un accord là
dessus
en tout cas moi je me battrai pour qu'on
trouve un accord là dessus
la question n'est d'ailleurs pas la
difficulté est ce qu'on donne les
investitures en décembre en juin la
question c'est avec quel état d'esprit
on choisit nos candidats je ne veux pas
d'un état d'esprit de sectes deux clubs
de supporters on choisira partout on
essaiera les meilleurs d'ailleurs mes
chers amis c'est bien ce qu'on a fait
pour les départementales et pour les
régionales chirurgie sans qu'il y ait eu
une polémique
à une exception près je dois le
reconnaître ou quelqu'un qui avait donné
sa parole ne l'a pas tenu donc pour moi
c'est clair c'est en juin dans un état
d'esprit qui est celui du rassemblement
enfin pour maxence on a plus de
confiance des français
est ce que je peux vous demander une
chose on reconnaît nos torts mais
arrêtons de nous couvrir la tête de
cendres
j'ai pas sur l'appui la confiance des
français mais j'observe aux régionales
il ya plus d'un français sur deux qui a
fauté au départemental ya près d'un
français sur deux qui a voté et que
c'est nous qui avons gagné les élections
il ya beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient
être dans cette situation là alors c'est
une maladie que j'ai bien connu alain tu
t'en souviens c'était je crois le milieu
des années 80 les réformateurs ou les
rénovateurs qui nous expliquait que ni
chirac ni mot savait faire la politique
mais que allait rénover la politique
seulement à l'arrivée il ya eu deux
présidents de la république
l'un s'appelait jacques chirac l'autre
c'était moi donc on n'est pas si mal
savoir faire la politique
le jour où vous n'êtes plus fier de
faire ce que vous faites ou s'excuser
d'avoir l'engagement qui est le vôtre
je ne connais pas un engagement plus
difficile que l'engagement politique
j'en ai assez qu'on dise que les élus
sont privilégiés ce n'est pas vrai
parce qu'un élu il est renvoyé à denis
tom à l'issue de son mandat sans rien
parce qu'un élu quand il se présente à
une élection il en moins une chance sur
deux d'être battu c'est la noblesse de
la politique
et quand on est élu on n'a pas à s'en
excuser donc ça suffit
c'est trop facile de critiquer les
politiques quand on est soi même
politique
soyez fiers de faire la politique
j'ajoute pour être tout à fait compris
que de mon point de vue nos assemblées
sont trop nombreuses et qu'il faudra
réduire le nombre de mandats de
parlementaire mais en revanche je dis
que faire des parlementaires qui
n'auraient pas le droit d'avoir un
mandat local
c'est une erreur monumentale parce qu'on
fera alors des spécialistes de la
législation et on privera les
territoires de toute capacité de
leadership
n'étant plus candidat à une élection
législative municipale régionale
départementale cantonales je peux donc
le dire sans risque que l'on m'accuse
d'être intéressant